We'll be doing some quick audio checks
over the next few minutes.
Can't tell if nothing is going through
or if the latency is just very high.
You are getting audio through. Okay.
Cool. I have absolutely no idea what the
delay is. Uh thank you for confirming.
It should be using my good mic.
I did a short test stream last night,
but I haven't streamed on
YouTube before.
Used Twitch for a little bit. I tried to
get this streaming on X, but I couldn't
get that to work.
Okay, perfect. Thanks for confirming.
So, the latency is at most like 10 15
seconds.
We'll be doing some quick audio checks
over the next few minutes.
Oh, I figured out the uh
the issue. It was that uh
Okay, I had the YouTube playback head
like 5 minutes behind. Perfect.
One small issue with this type of a
setup is that uh
I am for folks on Zoom.
This is also on
YouTube and uh right about now is when I
get spammed with
AI note-taking bot requests
as well as people filtering in
meeting.
I'm going to give this just a couple of
moments.
But uh
fair number of people
for invite.
Please do check that your mics are
muted.
You can We won't have a repeat of
my thesis defense. I fixed that at
least. But um
mics would
better muted. I don't know if there's an
option to mute all.
I said 9:00. We'll start at 9:00 uh
5 just because of the uh the Zoom room.
Nice.
Are you in Massachusetts or back in CA
yet? I am currently in Palo Alto. If
anybody on YouTube tell me if the
uh Zoom audio is correctly coming
through, that would be great. I believe
it should.
Oh, sorry if I just docked you. Oh, no,
no, you're fine. Uh, my stuff is all
public. I also, for reference, I have it
set up so it will not show uh, your
profile or your faces when you speak. I
believe the audio should still come
through, but it is showing my main
screen right now.
Perfect. All right.
Yes, I am in Palo Alto. I'm here for the
summer.
Uh, I'm happy to meet up pretty much
whatever whenever with anybody in or
around Palo Alto, and I will also be
making
some trips up to SF, though I'm hoping
to batch like two or three meetings a
day when I do go all the way up there.
Mike is relatively quiet. Thank you for
that comment. Let me see.
That any better?
It's relatively quiet. Thank you for
that comment. Let me see.
Somebody is echoing.
quiet. Thank you.
Let me see.
Okay.
Thank you for that.
Haven't streamed on YouTube before this
other than the small test.
A couple of my collaborators on here, so
if anybody wants to uh,
monitor YouTube chat and let me know if
anything breaks, that would be great.
Okay.
Let's get started.
Welcome
the PufferLib 1.0 launch.
It's a product project
not a product, all open source.
Project I'm fully excited to bring to
you guys.
I've been working on this for a while.
At least full-time since I graduated.
And this is something that I really
think is going to change
the way that we look at reinforcement
learning.
Not going to be anything big or flashy.
Really just a small set of low-level
tools, but it's going to make a big
difference in how easy it is to just do
work in reinforcement learning.
Want to keep this preamble short.
Today is not about talking heads.
It's about
a bunch of quick tech demos
and uh
going with this stuff can do.
So, the only thing is I'm going to start
with are where you can get all of these
demos and run them yourselves, as what
I'm running them on.
So,
what you see right here with the little
pufferfish prompt, this is puffer tank.
It is a container. We ship pre-built
images with a good version of PyTorch
and Python, plus all the annoying to
install dependencies. Not for pufferlib,
pufferlib doesn't have any, but for all
of the environments that I'm going to be
using. It makes it a lot easier. You've
got like a little hook, so if you use VS
Code, it's super easy. As you can see,
I'm not doing that. It's also very easy
just in a console.
Um
so, if you see I'm in this puffer tank
repos puffer tank folder right now.
You can get this on GitHub
/pufferai/puffertank.
Container's a little bit beefy, but
that's just PyTorch and Python.
Second, just muting uh
extra mics
on the Zoom call.
Okay.
You can get this right here.
pufferai puffertank
and
you can also get it on Docker Hub
pufferai/puffertank tag 1.0.
Starts up the container, and then the
box that I'm running this on, I messed
this HT into a desktop.
This is a 13900K.
with a single 4090. So, it's a nice
desktop, but it's a desktop. No 800s, no
800s, nothing.
So, the first thing that I'm going to do
is I'm going to
start in PufferLib, which is included,
run some of the examples. I'm going to
start with really the thing that
motivated PufferLib and the solution
that I found to it. And then you're
going to see how this one very small
wrapper is going to make everything so
much easier.
So, this is CleanRL's PPO Atari. I see
we have Costa uh in the chat on YouTube.
Amazing, amazing project.
So, I'm using it to uh improve over
because it's the best thing not to like
smash it as a baseline.
2800 or so steps per second, so close to
3,000. And then uh the difference
between this script and vanilla
So, the original, all I did was I added
uh multiprocessing vectorization from
Gymnasium, just so that uh it would use
multiple cores, and then I fixed uh an
unnecessary copy. And just so you can
see that I did actually improve it so
that we're using a stronger baseline,
not a weaker one.
The original is between 1,200 and 1,500
steps per second, depending on the
temperature where this desktop is. It is
currently in Florida.
So, what happens now if we want to run
this same sort of a script, this same
PPL, on a more complex, interesting
environment like NetHack, or we'll use
MiniHack for this.
Well,
we shouldn't have to change very much.
You're going to get rid of all these
Atari wrapper imports, add the MiniHack
ones,
change the M string, set a reasonable
batch size,
get rid of all these junk Atari
wrappers,
add some MiniHack stuff. It just needs a
compatibility wrapper for
the latest version of Gymnasium.
And then we're going to add in a
MiniHack network.
So,
the only other changes I have other than
this are moving a couple lines down a
little bit for demonstration purposes,
and uh changing the data type to match
MiniHack. So, assuming that you already
have a network suitable for MiniHack,
this is 5, maybe 10 minutes of work.
Unfortunately, this is not going to
work.
We have the error right here, which is
line 191.
And we can see that CleanRL is
allocating a big tensor for
observations.
This works fine for Atari and many
simpler environments that just have flat
observations like this. But many of the
more complex and interesting ones have
structured observations. Some of them
even have structured actions.
So,
that means that in order to actually use
CleanRL for something like MiniHack,
you're going to have to modify this obs
to be a big dictionary with a whole
bunch of different types, whole bunch of
different shapes and data. And then
anywhere that you use obs, you're going
to have to
make the appropriate changes.
So,
you're not going to be able to just dot
cuda these here cuz it's a dictionary.
Tensor dict and other stuff help with
this, but still you're going to have to
do some extra work.
Here, you're not going to be able to do
this because it's a dictionary.
Down here as well. Pretty much anywhere
you use obs, you're going to add a whole
bunch of extra logic. Now, sure this is
just like a little bit of engineering,
but I can tell you from experience and
anybody else who's worked with these
more complex environments can tell you
that this is just not a place that you
want to add complexity. It's
error-prone, it's really janky, it makes
this code really hard to use for other
projects and such, and this is often
sufficient motivation to just like not
want to use minihack. And even if you do
all of this, it can be pretty slow.
So,
we could also just do PufferPPO
minihack.
And now we're training minihack
at high 30 high 3,000s, close to 4,000
steps per second.
So, what did I change in order to make
this happen? Did I just go make all of
those changes and do it anyways?
I added one wrapper.
And it's not a minihack wrapper, it's a
gymnasium wrapper. A wrapper that will
work for whatever gymnasium environment,
almost any that we support.
Doesn't have to be added individually
either. It's just, you know, a pretty
good subset of gymnasium envs that will
soon be all of gymnasium envs.
And then, yeah, there's one like one
extra line with the agent uh creation
function that'll go away in a moment.
So, how do we do all of this with one
wrapper? How do we make this just work?
I'm going to open up on the right-hand
side
this demo file.
Here we can see the observation space of
minihack. It is a mess.
You have a whole bunch of different
elements in this dictionary. They're
boxes with different shapes. They even
have different data types.
And now, if we look at what happens once
we wrap it with puffer,
it is just about 13,000 uint8, so 13
kilobytes of flat data.
Now, you might think that sure, anybody
can write a quick flatten wrapper.
That's like 10 lines of code. No big
deal.
Uh and that the problem with that is
going to be that these 13,000 bytes
aren't particularly useful because you
need the structure of this when you go
to run your data through a network.
You're not just going to run your
network on flat bytes like this.
This is where the magic happens.
And there isn't much magic at all.
It's really just a NumPy feature that is
a little bit lesser known.
PufferLib infers this based on the
observation space.
This looks very similar and this this
stick but this dictionary
is special. This is a valid NumPy data
type.
This means that you can make a NumPy
data array with this data type.
And NumPy is going to create something
like a C struct for you.
This is contiguous memory and it can be
viewed either as flat bytes or with this
structure.
So, for demonstration purposes,
this is the wrapped environment, so this
is going to be 13 kilobytes of flat
data.
And we're just going to dot view this
data using this data type right here,
this dictionary.
And we can see that we recover the
original data from the flattened form
with all of the associated data types.
And this is a view operation that does
not have to copy. It is incredibly
quick.
This also works for vectorized data. So,
if I'm going to make a VecEnv right
here,
we reset the environment to get the flat
one,
and then we're going to dot view it to
get the structured obs.
This actually gives you
batched data in the exact format that
you would want it.
4 by 13 kilobytes goes to 4 by whatever
the sub temps or dimensions are.
And this works for
nested dictionaries, should work for
tuples, works for lots of different data
types.
Um, it's very general.
Now,
this is a very, very simple idea. It
went through many, many iterations to
get it to this. I didn't even know about
the NumPy thing when I started making
this and I had my own custom
implementations for a while,
but
it's incredibly powerful
because
it allows you to not have to care about
structured data in your vectorization
implementation,
in CleanRL,
or anywhere else other than in the
environment itself,
and in the forward function of your
model, right before you need the data
just in time.
And there're going to be a little bit of
uh of additional detail required for
that forward function, but really it's
what you see here.
So, you can write your vectorization
assuming that you have flat data and
it's going to work not just for Atari,
but for anything.
And you can write your CleanRL code, you
can actually leave it exactly the way it
is and run MiniHack.
But making this assumption,
you can optimize a whole bunch of things
along the way. So, not only is it going
to be simpler, it's going to be way
faster.
I'm going to run the PufferVec uh
Puffer's vectorization. So, same code
with Puffer's vec.
And now, instead of 4,000 steps per
second,
we're over 8,000.
And the environment itself will run it
over 50,000 with MiniHack because it has
some slow wrappers or at around 100,000
with NetHack.
You're very much bottlenecked by the
model here in CleanRL. But over 2x
performance for a drop-in and just to
show you that it is a drop-in,
That's all I changed.
I swapped the vectorization.
And as you can see, this annoying
signature went away.
So, this is what is IC is going to allow
us to just move RL onto more complex and
interesting environments and make it
very easy to do so. But, let's say that
you're a researcher or a hobbyist
working on something where you don't
really need all these structured
features just yet. And you know, maybe
you just want some speed ups on Atari or
some classic environments. And then
later on, if it's convenient, you'll
think about moving to more complex and
interesting ends.
Uh you know, if it's convenient to do so
and if they're faster and if it makes
sense.
Well, we actually have some speed ups
even for the simplest case. So, remember
we had 2,700 steps per second before
with PPO Atari. That's still not a fair
baseline to clean RL because the batch
size by default is just way too low.
So, we're going to just up the batch
size from 8 to 48 to be uh fair to clean
RL here.
And now we're going to get
mid to high
4,000 steps per second. I believe when I
checked this, it was 4,700.
Now, we're going to run PPO Atari
PPO Atari
uses our vectorization.
And it's a little bit faster. You're
very heavily bottlenecked by uh the
network here since the batch size is so
low. But, you know, we already get a
decent little increment. Uh it scales a
lot better, though.
4,700, we're going to get up to
if you can even read it, it's going so
fast.
If we let it even out, it will be right
around 8,000 steps per second.
8,000 steps per second.
So,
this is the difference between the large
RLPPO and Puffers.
A tiny little change.
All I did was I added in
PuffersVec,
and I slightly changed the the infos
format just for convenience.
That's all that's required to get this
like 50-60%
plus,
actually close to double in this case,
performance improvement.
We can go a lot farther than this. This
is just what I wanted to show you exists
with almost no code change required. The
performance improvements are much larger
for structured environments, uh for
which Gymnasium and other standard vec
implementations are less optimized or
very often just don't work at all.
So, for the next set of demos, we're
going to go into the main PufferLib
repository.
And this demo.py is just going to run
our somewhat souped-up version of
CleanRL. Uh I'll show you that there's
no real additional magic to it in a bit.
Um, but for now just it's clean RL with
additional logging and like one
important additional feature.
This is going to give us a nice
dashboard as soon as it finishes making
all the environments.
You get this nice render in your
terminal.
Importantly, you get close to 16,000
training steps per second, another
factor of two. So, from 4.7k all the way
up to 16k
with minimal introduction of complexity
as I will demonstrate soon.
Most of the additional code is going to
actually just be for generating this
dashboard and getting these detailed
metrics and hardware utilization and all
of that.
But before we go into the uh
nitty-gritty details where I demonstrate
that to you for certain,
let's take a look at what we can do with
this simple little repository.
We're going to run a simple environment
that we can train quickly like MiniGrid.
and we are going to set it as a baseline
for Weights & Biases.
I'm going to actually get out of this uh
box and back to my laptop. I'm going to
run the exact same container I have
on the remote machine.
And
I'm going to go into here.
We can see this is running at 40k steps
per second. So, by the time I finish
typing this, it's already done running a
million train steps.
Link to Weights & Biases.
Now I can pull that model down.
Evaluate locally.
Going to spawn on my other screen, so
let me go grab the window.
Here we have this agent that we just
trained in 30 seconds.
On this desktop, running on my laptop,
solving MiniGrid and rendering.
And MiniGrid is a really simple
environment, but the nice thing with
Puffer is that this same sort of a
workflow is going to work with just
about anything.
Let's run NetHack.
I don't have a pre-trained model for
everything, but I can at least run a
random policy on it.
And since this is ASCII, we can even
render it on the terminal just with a
little bit of flickering.
So, here we have NetHack running.
Uh for researchers on classic tasks.
We actually include a few of our own
environments here with PufferLib.
They're very simple.
This is I actually have a baseline for
this as well.
This is a very simple test env. It's
incredibly useful cuz you can train it
in like 10 seconds, and it will tell you
90% of the time that you've messed
something up in your environment. Plus,
it'll render like this locally in a
terminal. Just trying to get to the
blue.
And
let's show just a couple more.
Big Fish seems appropriate for
PufferLib.
Procgen has had some uh some infra
issues that
needed some working around, but
I realized that before when I dragged
the window over, I might not have
dragged it to uh
where you could see it with my camera.
But here you have Big Fish.
Procgen can run up from like 50,000
steps per second with the C++ bit
vectorization. It's up now to 150,000
without needing C++ vectorization using
PufferLib.
That makes it a lot easier to work with
and faster to boot.
And the last one I'm going to show you
is Neural MMO.
Neural MMO doesn't have a local
renderer, so I just wrote one very
quickly so I could just show you that
this will work for fantasy multi-agent
MMOs as complicated as Neural MMO.
Here you have
in yellow all the agents running around
and in red all the NPCs.
So now that I've shown you everything
that is included in this demo,
at least for uh training and inference,
let me show you just how truly simple it
is.
And our souped-up clean PufferRL is 700
some odd lines. This is a total about
1,000 line demo.
And as you're going to see, the vast
majority of this is just devoted to all
the profiling code and the dashboard.
There's like 100 additional lines of
actual code complexity uh added on top
of CleanRL.
Here's our init function.
One screen of code.
Sets up the dashboard, sets up
utilization, sets up an experience
buffer, which is going to be the one
additional thing. Add some features like
torch compilation option, your
optimizer. That's all.
Here's your eval function. It is 75
lines of code.
There
two or three main differences versus
vanilla CleanRL. One is you have all of
these decorators and contexts. This is
purely to get accurate
profiling for the dashboard, very useful
in diagnosing how you can
speed up your learning loop.
The second major change is right here.
This is DataVecEnv receive.
And we have DataVecEnv
uh right up here, send.
This is an asynchronous environment API.
Uh your algorithm is still PPO. It is
still on policy.
However,
BufferLib introduces a Python
implementation of EnvPool.
EnvPool's a project that allows you to
run
more environments than you need per
batch, such that the ones that you don't
currently have observations from are
running in the background while your
model is doing its forward pass. So,
you can drive your environment time down
to zero, technically, if uh it only
takes the time of your forward pass.
This is where the other 2x performance
improvement comes from. And the crucial
thing with BufferLib is that it will
work for just about any environment,
compared to the original EnvPool
project, which requires you to have
bound C++ implementations for your
environments.
And it is very fast. Usually will give
you a 2x improvement for most
environments, unless your environment is
really, really slow, uh in which case
you've seen like 30, 40% even then.
The 75 lines for eval, including some
additional junk that I need to get rid
of. This is specific to a couple
projects I'm working on.
Train loop here is I believe around 150
or so lines. This is even more similar
to original clean RL.
The main differences here, the
experience buffer,
and then I cythonize generalized
advantage estimation
just because it was the bottleneck for
really fast environments.
Just for thoroughness, I'll show you
that there is
no magic here. This is your generalized
advantage estimation.
This is me adding some types and now
it's 20 to 50 times faster.
Only makes a difference for really fast
environments.
Okay, so train loop.
This is all from where we started
before. This is all just standard clean
RL.
This is wandb integration.
This is checkpointed.
And there's the dashboard print right
there.
Absolutely no smoke and mirror.
And then from here down
there's going to be the one experience
buffer at addition, which is 100 lines
of code, and then the rest of this is
just dashboard.
I guess there's a little checkpoint as
well.
Dashboard dashboard. Okay, here's your
experience buffer. It's 100 lines of
code. This is actually a little bit
complicated, but overall it's a pretty
small amount of complexity to add for
the amount of performance it gives and
it doesn't really mess with the APIs too
much. Um
what this thing has to do is allocate
you a flat buffer of data so that when
you store
your data
right here
you store the env_id
and you store the step of that data.
This tells you how to actually order
your data
when you're running training.
And then when you sort the training
data, it sorts the training data.
And then it just reshapes it after it's
been sorted so that all of the steps
from
the episode are contiguous.
And it gives you your batches. That's
all this thing does, 100 lines of code,
little bit of complexity, well worth it.
The rest of this is all just uh
checkpoint and then
one screen of code for the whole eval
demo that I showed. All the rendering
stuff is this one screen of code because
PopperLib gives you a consistent
environment for single and multi-agent
and makes everything behave really well.
So, as a result, like
one line for MC environments,
couple lines for frame environments,
one conditional for if the agent is
recurrent or not,
and that's all.
Everything else is dashboard.
This is all just rich printing
of uh dashboard stuff.
That is
700 some odd lines of the code.
Uh as for why their runner file is 300
lines,
I wanted to make it really
user-friendly, so I made the help menu
dynamic.
If you do breakout like that, it'll
actually give you the policy args for
breakout. It'll give you env args for
breakout if there are any. So, this is
just computed based on your environment
dynamically.
Um that is most of the code in demo is
just doing that.
So, here's your fancy config loader.
It's a YAML file. You don't even need
it. It's just for hyper parameters to
make stuff easier.
For generating the uh the dashboard as
well. There's some arg par stuff in
here.
Here's your make policy function
for recurrent and not recurrent
policies.
Here's wandb integration.
Here's sweeps integration for
hyperparameter tuning with wandb.
Here's your train function
that selects
if you want to run serially,
multi-processed, or with Ray. We have
all of these. Ray is usually really
slow, but it's good
uh multi-machine, I suppose, for really
slow environments.
And then we have vector make.
Make your vec env. Your policy.
And alternate between eval train, eval
train, eval train.
Everything else here
is arg par shenanigans.
So, all the args that you can specify.
Here is the wandb baseline thing. It
literally is just uploading and
downloading a PyTorch uh .pt.
That's all that there is to this.
Here's the call for the render demo.
Here's the call for train.
And then we have a couple other nice
tools for you.
Sweeps.
Auto tuning is fun. This is how you tell
your how do you make your environment
fast for your machine. This is a
relatively new addition.
.n
batch. I believe it's train.n batch
size.
So, this is going to find the best
settings for your machine for breakout
if you want a batch size of 24.
And set like limitations on how much RAM
and stuff you want it to consume. It'll
just profile single core first, and then
it will uh attempt to guess best
settings, and it will evaluate a whole
bunch of different settings.
So,
these are all the tools
that I currently have
included with the demos for PufferLib.
This library itself is very simple and
restricted. It's mainly just
here's a wrapper to make all your
environments behave nicely with whatever
reinforcement learning you want. If you
do that, then you can actually take the
opportunity to make a whole bunch of
optimizations to vectorization. So,
we'll go ahead and do that.
And then all the demos are just very
simple built out of that, where those
wrappers are doing the heavy lifting.
There will be an archive manuscript as
soon as the repository hits 300 stars,
which could be in 2 minutes if
all wouldn't mind the starring
PufferAI/PufferLib
on GitHub. I'm working on this full-time
since I've graduated, so it really helps
me out. I'd appreciate that.
Um
and that will include details of the
vectorization and such imple mentation.
Since I know I'm going to have questions
on that,
at a high level, the major optimizations
in vectorization that make it this fast
are the assumption on PufferLib
emulation, so you only handle flat data.
Observations are allocated as big
tensors in shared memory.
So, the workers will write directly into
that shared memory without having to
ever stack or concatenate data.
We support multiple environments per
process, so you don't crowd too many
processes.
The workers themselves,
they don't rely on pipes for the most
part or queues for sending data around.
They actually busy wait on values in
shared memory, which completely
eliminates interprocess overhead cuz
they're just waiting on a value to
change that is not locked or anything.
And infos are aggregated over episodes
by default. That's one of the wrappers
that we have. And we only will send the
summed infos
once per episode, and that's the only
time that you have to pipe anything.
That's to save like 40 microseconds or
whatever, but it makes a big difference
for fast environments.
Those are all of the major
optimizations. Heck, I'll be happy to
take more technical questions on it or
on the emulation, and I'll be happy to
show code. But thank you very much. I
really hope that this is going to be
useful for everyone in RL. I hope this
gets RL into way more hobbyist hands for
doing cool projects that would have been
previously been hard. I hope that for
researchers this gets us looking at more
complex and
environments by default. And I think
that industry is going to find this a
very useful simplification of very heavy
tools that would normally be required as
well. So, thank you and I'll take
questions. Please note that this is
streamed on YouTube. Audio should be
going through to you.
So, your profile or your camera should
not
I'll be alternating from
Zoom and from that row.
You can just speak or if you prefer,
then
type in chat.
I'll both of those are
Oh, perfect.
Apparently the repo hit 300 already. So,
I will archive this
either right after this or whenever the
good timing is so it shows up in the
morning.
And then the paper will be up tomorrow.
It's a technical manuscript. It has
mostly full details on the vectorization
without putting like you know, the level
of code that you would that you would
not be able to submit to a conference
because it is just like the RLC and Nerf
submission.
Can you discuss a bit
Question from Zoom is can you discuss a
bit what if at all one might have to do
to connect your environment abstraction
to new environment we're developing?
Absolutely nothing.
If your environment is in any of the two
or I think we're just DeepMind Embs as
well, but really any of the two standard
environment formats, gymnasium or
um
single agent or petting zoo for
multi-agent,
you can just add the one-line wrapper on
top of your environment, and it will be
taken care of for you by the flatten and
unflatten. That's all you have to do.
There are no like huge heavy additional
abstractions. It's just a flatten
unflatten.
Um there are some restrictions on it. We
don't support all subspaces of gymnasium
uh yet,
but uh and we're specifically we're not
doing control actions just yet, but most
environments it's going to be like some
nested dictionary conver- uh combination
of boxes with different data types, and
if you can just put your data in that
format, it will work.
And relatedly, Ariel asks, "Does it
support arbitrarily nested observations
actions?" Yes, it does. That tends to be
tricky for optimizing buffers. Yes, it
is very tricky. That's why we flatten
them all, and then we don't ever have to
deal with it.
Um I should mention with the actions,
we're not doing continuous just yet.
It's probably a hundred lines of code in
PufferLib that I just haven't written
yet to do continuous.
I don't work with control environments
very often. Uh that is planned. If
anybody wants to help with that, that
would be awesome. But uh for now, it is
any nested combination of discrete and
multi-discrete,
which will cover fancy stuff like Neural
MMO uh and many other environments as
well.
Take some questions from YouTube. "Does
PufferLib also improve the speed when no
vectorization is used like single CPU
single env?" Uh so,
it n
you you shouldn't expect it to because
in that case, if you have one uh
one process with one environment, like
you really don't have to do anything to
shuffle the data around. The one thing
that I can think of is that we do let
you dot cuda your data in one call. Um
and then you unpack it in the forward
pass of having to do a whole bunch of
different dot cuda calls. So, that will
definitely simplify things. And
actually, you know, the one thing now
that I'm thinking about it is that even
if you have single environment, um
when you're collecting data buffers,
you're still going to have to make all
those crazy modifications to clean RL uh
without pufferlib. So, it definitely
helps simplify. And by simplifying,
probably will get uh some speed
improvements just by not having to
optimize all that stuff, I guess.
If I use Ray RLlib, which already
vectorizes my env, is there any point in
still using pufferlib?
As far as I am aware,
RLlib is just completely broken.
I've spent so much time trying to get it
to work. I've offered to go to the off
the Anyscale office in person for free
for several weeks to fix stuff.
It just hasn't worked.
So, if you actually have RLlib working
and you're happy with it, then
you can keep it. I would still suggest
not using puffer's vectorization maybe,
but at least throwing our emulation
wrapper on the environment. Because then
RLlib isn't going to have to do whatever
crazy stuff they do to handle structured
observations natively. They're going to
be able to trigger their much better
tested code paths that are used for like
Atari and stuff. Uh and that's generally
one of the biggest benefits of pufferlib
is even if you have a framework that
technically supports uh all this
structured stuff on paper, you trigger
the simplest and most common code path
that is tested against Atari when you
use our wrapper. And you can get a lot
of uh speed improvements as a result
because usually the more complicated
code paths are not as well optimized.
So, there is still a benefit, yes.
When you have a heavy framework like
RLlib that doesn't let you vectorize or
like swap in your own vectorization
easily, you don't get to use our nice
vec
benefit, but you still get to use our
emulation.
Do you know if there's from a learning
perspective a bottleneck on how much vec
em should be?
Like should we always have as much vec
ems as we
This is a good question. So,
one of the reasons why the settings for
most learning libraries are so terrible
by default,
like eight is a very common batch size
for Atari, is that people are hyper
focused in on sample efficiency for some
reason in
in RL, which yeah, makes sense if you're
doing this for a robot, but RL is not
just about robots, right? There are tons
of tasks for which you have a simulator,
the simulator is fast, the simulator has
infinite data,
you kind of just want to suck up as much
data as you can from the environment.
You do get diminishing returns
at very large batch sizes if the
environment is not complicated enough.
There's a very good OpenAI blog post on
this from like five years ago as to the
optimal batch sizes for different
environments. For complex ems like Dota,
it's huge.
And in pretty much all cases,
it's going to be bigger than eight.
Any other questions?
Folks can feel absolutely free to to
just speak on Zoom if they're
comfortable with that. You're not going
to be messing up the recording. This is
like the casual tech demo presentation
version. I will be making a separate
higher level video for like broader
broader interest on PufferLib in the
next few weeks.
That was one of the star milestone.
Does it support vectorizing environments
across multiple machines?
No, I'm focused on single node for the
time being because that's the most
common setting for academic researchers
and hobbyists. However,
Buffer's vectorization is in no way
dependent on torch
or any framework.
So, if you have a GPU vectorization
setup
that lets you just run your models, you
know, on different machines and whatever
is going to be associated with it, run
your code on different machines, then my
suggestion is
to simply use the cores on each machine
to feed data into the GPUs on that
machine.
So, you don't necessarily need to write
like a specialized RL vectorization
thing if you do that. You just need
something that can take data from the
machine that the GPUs are on and feed it
into them and then handle
synchronization. That's a heck of a lot
easier problem than like an end-to-end
RL RL setup. It's not going to be like
perfectly optimal, but I think as you've
seen from some of these performance
demos,
you can get pretty darn fast while
keeping things very, very simple.
What do you think of SB3? SB3 is a very
nice project for for many people in RL,
especially for many newcomers.
Uh
it's a great bit of work.
It's kind of like this in-between point
for something like CleanRL and something
like heavy like an industry library. Um
it's
easier to hack on than like RLlib, good
luck.
Um
but it's still a lot harder to do stuff
with than say CleanRL. It's a lot harder
to like customize stuff if you're a
researcher and you want to edit random
bits of code. So, I used CleanRL
partially for that reason, but also
partially because SB3
doesn't have multi-agent support and is
like actively not going to be moving in
the direction to support that anytime.
So, it's really nice for me to be able
to have this one demo that just shows
everything including like neural MMO.
Um but for all the single agent stuff,
you can totally use puffer lab with it.
In fact, I would suggest that you do
because the SB3 implementation for
structured observations and actions is
really really unoptimized and you should
get a decent performance increment just
out of using our emulation.
If anybody wants to like
see about porting some of these or like
moving the vec into SB3 or like letting
SB3 use outside vectorization
implementations, that would be awesome.
But at the very least for now for SB3
and just about any other library, the
emulation wrappers should all be
compatible.
Any gym.mfs will be compatible.
It work the other way around. The vector
env be a gym.vector env. So,
I thought about doing that.
And
the reason I didn't do that is because
like a lot of libraries don't even use
I I don't think SB3 even uses it, does
it?
Actually, does anybody know does SB3
use? Yeah, okay. So, like so many
libraries kind of make their own vec
anyways that it's not really useful as a
standardization, right? Like the gym vec
env adds some extra requirements. It
doesn't really give you a lot simply
because not enough things use it.
There are some issues I think with the
vec API that make people want to roll
their own. If there were a standard one,
I'd be very happy to make it compatible
so that you could like just swap in
puffer's vec. That would be awesome. But
that is going to take some
cooperation from a lot of different
library maintainers.
I will say it's very very similar.
If I just open it up here, this is a
good opportunity.
So first of all,
843 lines for serial, multi-processing,
ray backends, and auto tune. Not huge.
So,
we keep the same
for step, it's obs rewards terminals
truncated infos. That's the gymnasium
API. Reset, it's obs infos. That's the
standard API.
There's also a send and receive.
So send that doesn't return.
Send doesn't return anything.
And then receive, we have to return some
additional stuff that's API breaking. So
this agent IDs, this is like env pool.
You need to know what envs you're
getting stuff from if you're running
async.
And then I additionally add this masks
thing that tells you
which agents are alive. It's really
niche,
but it's incredibly needed
for multi-agent. Multi-agent basically
doesn't work at all without this.
Um
the actual other stuff on the API, we
support like num envs, this gym vec
support, what is it?
Single obs Yeah, we have single
observation and action spaces.
Um and most of the other stuff in there.
I think there were like a couple weird
functions I didn't want to totally add
if the standardization wasn't going to
buy me anything, but it's really, really
close.
Maybe I can jump in like regarding that
here. Because the story with vector ends
in gymnasium was that initially it was
kind of ad hoc and kind of And now
we're trying to slowly bring it up to
date, but I mean
as you might know, the development of
gymnasium has been pretty slow Yep.
recently.
But
the vector end like a more proper vector
of end API is either already merged or
is going to be merged in the nearest
patch whenever that happens.
So then, I mean
what we could consider and this is
obviously in no way binding is I would
have to evaluate the like you know, the
proper lip stuff and then talk to
several people.
But we could try to build some kind of
let's say soft integration
We already have that. Okay. Here's a gym
because
one of the things in the new vector API
is that you can select different ways of
of vectorization. That's what we have
synchronous, asynchronous. We can have a
custom like you know, if you can just
vectorize your environment in numpy.
And we keep it we're keeping it open
because at some point we're planning to
add an end pool integration. That also
for various reasons didn't happen and I
don't think it will ever happen. I never
said it would happen, but this leak
looks general enough
that it might just make sense to have
say okay, if you want to have proper lip
vectorization just do gym make vec and
then
method proper lip
and then just get a proper lip
environment and there's probably going
to be some light conversion layer to
make sure that it adheres to the API,
but it shouldn't be a big problem with
gymnasium. And then we could
And then what you would do for that is
you would um
you just add like a warning if proper
lip isn't installed instead of adding
proper as a depth, right?
Yep. Yep. I'd be good with that. Yeah, I
don't want to like vend I don't as long
as it's not like vendering vendering it
that I have to maintain an extra thing
or like adding it as a hard depth, that
sounds like a great idea.
Yeah, we have our own make by the way.
Like
the make is pretty similar.
There's like some extra stuff in here
because there's some extra checks just
because of the N full API. Shoot
yourself in the foot by making stuff not
divisible by num workers. Um there are a
few additional weird kinks that I'm
still working out like
uh our workers, one of the biggest
optimization you make that nobody does
is you
strictly limit yourself to the number of
workers per core and then you make the
workers busy wait on
um
make them busy wait on values in shared
memory instead of waiting on pipes.
Uh there are a couple edge cases where
that can do weird things, but for like
almost every environment I tried, it's a
huge win.
Um
but yeah, I think that timeline-wise,
probably that will match up when as soon
as that you guys are ready to do
something like that, then this should be
good to go for that. It's already like
you'll see in the archive manuscript
tomorrow. We tested on a bunch of
different environments.
Ideal world, what for you is the best RL
researcher library stack if my goal is
to train
good policies as fast as possible
disregarding sample.
Okay, so
this is what my goal is uh in the next
few months. I want you to be able to
have like single node really fast good
training with complex and interesting
environments.
This is not the only thing that I'm
releasing this. There're going to be a
couple other things that I have in the
works as well.
Um I think you're going to be able to do
way better than anyone would think
on one machine while still keeping
everything very simple.
After that,
then yeah, we'll have to think about
distributed.
I don't know how PyTorch is with
distributed. I think Kostas told me it's
a not a fun time.
So,
we'll see. But, my hope is that we're
not going to have to do like super
specific RL things if when if and when
we want distributed to
um
But, yeah, I CleanRL is kind of the
optimal thing. And for scale, like Clean
bus really, really good. I wish you
could have Clean but in PyTorch that
worked. I think that there are some
wrinkles with PyTorch
vectorization. Um not vectorization,
multi-machine
uh to make that happen.
But, hey, maybe it's in the future.
Still, like
the vast majority of people that are
doing stuff, yeah, like industry is
going to want multi-node and uh we'll
work on that, I'm sure. You can still
drop in our vectorization if you have
like single node.
Like, you're getting data from the
specific node on which need data for
like the GPUs on the same machine, if
that makes
You can still use our vectorization in
that case. You just need to have like
the distributed multi-machine for the
model.
Um
But, my hope is that this is going to
make it RL so much easier for the vast
majority of people and we're just going
to see this explosion of lots of cool
games and interesting environments and
simulators getting solved because
they're so much easier and faster to
work.
Last couple minutes here in case folks
have any other questions.
Hey, guess I will add um
there's a Discord. I'm very active there
with support, so this is
brand new launch.
There is anything wrong with it.
discord.gg/puffer
easy to remember.
There's a library which
is GitHub
Puffer AI/
AI/Puffer lib.
There's also Puffer Tank.
And then the docs are puffer
ai.github.io.
I just pushed 1.0 docs before this. Case
they have not synced yet, just add /dev.
Those will be synced later today at the
latest if they're not already.
Okay then. Well,
thank you everybody.
And I will continue to host
monthly-ish
meetings
over the summer. So,
if anyone has cool stuff to share,
uh generally around this space, let me
know.
Thank you all.